[Music]
in celebrity shaming news submitted by
Bashara bella thorne posted her nude
photos ahead of a head of a hacker but
Whoopi Goldberg blamed her for taking
them in the first place I saw this I
don't know anything
whose bella thorne I just know she was
dating that Tana Tana mojo mojo really a
youtuber she's like an akan girl oh they
were dating I don't know there was that
some people were saying they were
debating but then like other people were
like heard Tana was like now we're
really dating
what's gay bathing it's when you pretend
to be gay for attention oh yeah we're
like to get a crowd of support behind
you yeah yeah I'd like to be part of
that should be illegal so this is Bella
Thorne and Whoopi Goldberg in case you
forgot what they look like she was the
same who Whoopi Goldberg no my whole
life she's looked like that sister act
yeah she just keeps so this one took
naked pictures and Whoopi is getting on
her for taking what's the bottom of an
orange you know what a scrunched up
bottom of a orange look people still
getting hacked
that's what Whoopi was saying that's
what I don't understand how was that
like or is iCloud getting hacked - where
was her pictures that they got hacked
well that's what Whoopi was saying that
it was in the cloud or something I'm not
exactly sure but so Bella Thorne she
ended up tweeting this [ __ ] you and the
power you think you have over me I'm
gonna write about this in my next book
and then angry faces and then some nudes
so these are text messages that the
hacker is sending her of her own photos
and so she's like oh he was like hey
what you do is taking my head yo Bella
and then this other one has got all the
videos and like you see your titties
everywhere so she posted like a
screenshot of a note oh and she's she
wrote yesterday as you all know all my
[ __ ] was hacked for the last 24 hours
I've been
with my own nudes I feel gross I feel
watched I feel someone has taken
something from me that i only wanted one
special person to see he has sent me
multiple nudes of other celebs he won't
stop with me or them he will just keep
going for too long I let a man take
advantage of me over and over in a
[ __ ] sick of it I'm putting this out
because it's my decision now you don't
get to take yet another thing from me I
can sleep tonight better knowing I took
my power back you can't control my life
you never will
here's a photo season threatening me
with in other words here's my boobies so
here [ __ ] you and the last 24 hours I
have been crying instead of celebrating
my book while doing my book press oh
yeah the FBI will be at your house
shortly so watch your [ __ ] back
yeah how many licenses should get I
don't know and this should get more
likes than hoja so Whoopi's mad at her
so this is what will be set for taking
the pictures this is what Whoopi said
yeah what did Whoopi say yeah I need to
know
all right so Whoopi was saying that once
you take a photo and it goes into the
cloud it's an available to any hacker so
if you know that we're in 2019 and this
is already a problem you're a celebrity
and that you're famous then you should
be mindful of that happening so that's
pretty much what Whoopi was saying and
then Bella ended up responding on her
Instagram story's pretty disgusting you
know I feel pretty disgusting won't be
knowing everyone's ceiling you know my
[ __ ] and and I just want to say that me
watching this interview make me feel
really bad about myself and I hope
you're happy I really do I really hope
you're so [ __ ] happy because you know
I I don't really want to go on the view
anymore because I don't really want to
be beaten down by a bunch of older women
for my body and my sexuality so I'm
gonna cancel my interview because saying
if you take a sexy photo then it
basically deserves to get leaked like
don't be surprised at all and don't feel
sorry for yourself so if I go out to a
party drinking and I want to dance on
the dance floor do I deserve to be raped
too because to me I see those two things
really [ __ ] similar okay yeah I agree
with her I mean because here's the thing
like I personally have never taken a
nude photo because of that because I
don't want it to ever get leaked or
whatever but that was my choice like
people should be able to take nude
photos of their [ __ ] bodies and send
them to whoever they want without being
worried about getting hacked well just
so you know if you send a nude photo to
a guy he for sure he's showing that to
all of his friends or he's keeping it
for long not just yet I mean but you can
don't be stupid
it's big like this is a precious picture
of me I have a question that you know
did Joe show you all my news oh yeah for
sure
yeah I got left out of that party
attitude I'm just saying so maybe my guy
is better than most guys neither you
never need I doubt it I actually
understand both sides I mean I mean it's
like I think that if you take nude
photos then you have to be you have to
say to yourself I'm okay if this gets
out right yeah I mean I think Whoopie
was trying to say to you though but she
just kind of said in a really stupid way
yeah like you she was like victim like
blaming her no she was blaming someone
that's wrong but I think I think she
probably meant to say what you're saying
which I can agree to it's like you just
kind of have to give that up and be like
this might happen and if it does happen
am I gonna be okay with that like Nicki
kind of thought that too and was like if
this happens I'm not gonna be okay with
that so I'd rather just play it safe
it's what the rape thing is really as an
analogy that I never stressed so but but
but you should be able to walk around
naked and not worry about getting raped
you should be able to do it right I mean
that's not the reality of the world but
you should be able to I believe that but
it's just the same as like being
pro-choice like for example I personally
would never get an abortion but that's
my choice like I'm happy that other
people have the choice and I think that
you shouldn't blame like lick the victim
of someone getting hacked or whatever
and it wasn't like it was one of her
boyfriends friends or something that
that showed the picture around because
that's that is like the thing that you
could think of as a precaution but this
is like a hacker like there's no way
but I'd like to know the details of what
the hack actually is yeah you know it's
like this so vague like it's like it's
somebody actually hacking iCloud I don't
yeah because that's a big problem like
we should all be worried like everybody
right now they just take a second
already like don't you guys remember
that huge leap that was a that was a
third party app a third party yet so
it's like if you have like you know how
you say like give Twitter access or give
something access it's one of those type
of apps that they were using so and I
just think that Whoopie was a little
harsh yeah and but but but if she would
have just not been so harsh just to say
like hey you're making this because this
girl's being so dramatic about
everything it's like yo yeah
you you were naked I don't think I don't
feel like she was being dramatic
I'm no I'm talking about not in that
what shoes I'm just saying even from the
whole event
yeah I'm just saying it's like I think
how she handled it I just think how she
handled it is great it's like look
alright I showed I could be naked for
this special person whoever this special
person is and she's like okay this guy's
trying to threaten me so I'm like okay
here it is release it who cares
yeah I mean and so at that point it's
like I say own that choice so it doesn't
look so hard you know to me because
she's making it outwards like it like it
like it was like gun to her head it was
like it turns out that it was that so
she's saying that they found out who it
was it was really young kid and so she's
not gonna press charges because she
doesn't want to ruin someone's life that
they made a really bad decision when
they were really young so a lot of
people are speculating that this was all
just the publicity for her book that's
not gonna say if the photos are too
highly produced I'm like did you want to
leak them and were you leaking them
yourself or did someone really like
highly produced for her crying seems to
me that just thinks I'm taking there
just to his Botox and fillers like she
couldn't make a wrinkle in her face no
but for me it's like I think they're
like when that big hack happened before
the one that I was most uh you like I
was like like oh that sucks for was
Kirsten Dunst because the picture looked
intimate like the picture clearly look
like it was for somebody that she really
cared about you know I mean you could
tell then it was like I don't want to be
a party to this
but like Jennifer Lawrence's pictures I
was like are you 24 and you just like
you know I mean like you know you're
just like I'm sexy she was down for it
so it's like I don't know if she
necessarily minded did that got out I
mean I think a lot of these young
starlets don't mind that it's getting
out because they're getting attention
yeah but one thing I have a question is
like what's where do you draw the line
from victim-blaming and also telling
people that they have a responsibility
to protect themselves I think saying it
like that yeah cuz I think I think I
feel like that's what Whoopi was trying
to do like saying you have a
responsibility understanding technology
understanding your status that people
are gonna come after you yeah so all of
these little starlets and stuff for like
against Whoopi now and I don't know if
it's just cuz I'm old but I'm likely it
would be alone like I don't think I
don't think that's fair I think what
Whoopi's trying to say and I think that
other girl Bella's getting drunk and
getting raped examples kind of extreme I
think what Whoopi's trying to say it's
like yeah you can buy a nice purse and
no one should rob you but just know that
if you are flaunting a nice ass purse
and someone comes in robbed you don't
also say where the [ __ ] did that come
from
mm-hmm so like if you are taking these
photos I think like you everyone should
have the right to turn their own photos
you didn't do what they want but if you
do get hacked and we know it's a reality
that it happens you can't be that sad
like you're you're the victim a hundred
percent you know I guess it's a risk
you're willing if you jump on the
freeway you might get an accident it's a
double-edged sword yes I mean I don't
know I don't necessarily necessarily
agree with what you just said that [ __ ]
up and say something really bad yeah you
know but I'm just saying it's like it's
like it's like this is different it's
like if you are gonna wear you know like
if you're gonna wear have a nice fancy
outfit on and you go into a not nice
fancy part of town then you you can't be
surprised if I are you gonna get
unwanted attention yeah but it should be
okay like like like the example you gave
us like you should be okay for women to
be passed out drunk with a guy and wake
up and not be raped yes real people that
are supporting fellow they're pretty
much saying like you know stop focusing
on victim blaming and victim shaming
some
like we should be after the guy who yeah
pack der in the first place exactly well
they are gonna go after him but I think
we'll be also saying as an older person
like a sort of like matriarchal
character yeah she's just trying to say
like hey but when you only reprimand the
girl don't say anything about the guy
like hey guys stop [ __ ] hacking it's
not cool then it looks like the girls
only the only one to blame but you're
not but those people aren't gonna listen
anyway like you're not gonna like go on
TV and give a public service
announcement hey everybody don't hack
people those people those people don't
give a [ __ ] you know I mean they don't
care but so you won't do it anymore
I know he's like oh god I can't Whoopi
says not so I'm not gonna do it anymore
so I don't know I mean it's but I think
that this particular the way she's
acting I don't believe her like I'm not
I'm not fully on board with heard her
dramatics about it you know to me eyes
especially after people like Kim
Kardashian grow to like such massive
Heights from stuff like this it's really
not gonna be detrimental I mean I get
that it's personal and you don't want
people to see your titties but also it's
not career ruining like nothing Bad's
gonna happen what I'm saying is those
pictures weren't even like if someone's
gonna blackmail you it should be like
you know like like you're spreading the
lips like you know you're with your
bands brother or something I think it's
the fact that he was using this against
her that made her feel disgust like
blackmailing her yeah and like taking
control of her life like I'm gonna
release these photos it could've been a
credit card yeah he's like I'm gonna put
this out there she's just like not what
the [ __ ] I should choose the phone it
out there yeah exactly more scared on my
credit card than my naked body also free
the titties man like that that's another
thing I have a problem with like yeah
let's do it right now
[Music]
[Music]